l'école n'est pas un milieu naturel pour
tous les enfants et j'en veux pour
preuve le livret scolaire
nous avons tous eu des livret scolaire
nous avons tous dans le coeur et dans la
tête ces souvenirs de notre apporter à
la maison en guettant dans le regard de
nos parents la fierté ou en craignant
peut-être un peu de déception
en tous les cas que d'émotions le livret
scolaire véhicule ce que nous valons à
l'école et pour un enfant l'école c'est
le premier lieu de vie après la maison
pourtant ça n'est qu'un petit bout de
papier sur lequel nous allons constater
le chemin parcouru les différentes
étapes franchies mais pour un enfant
pour un parent c'est tellement et puis
c'est une évidence mais en tant que
parent en tant que maman j'ai été privé
de livrets scolaires
mon petit garçon louis quand il était en
petite section a rapporté un livret qui
était vide et sur ce livret il était
écrit il a beaucoup crié mais il fait
des progrès alors j'ai été projeté dans
un grand moment d'anxiété et surtout je
ne savais absolument pas où il se
situait dans son développement dans ses
compétences
même si quand on est en face d'un tout
petit finalement on a le temps de voir
venir
mais assez rapidement un moment
douloureux est arrivé et nous avons eu
un diagnostic et notre petit garçon
était atteint et toujours atteints d'une
forme très sévère d'autisme en apprenant
l'autisme de louis bien sûr ce fut un
choc pour nous mais surtout j'ai compris
que pour les enseignants ce serait
vraiment compliqué cet enfant
il ne savait pas comment le prendre et
surtout il ne savais pas du tout comment
l'évaluer
comment lui proposait d'acquérir de
nouvelles connaissances de nouvelles
compétences
comment l'intégrer dans la classe
pourtant c'est un enfant avant d'être un
handicapé et face à cette question nous
nous sommes retrouvés devant un vide un
premier vide l'année suivante un second
vide et ça m'a posé la question de
l'évaluation
comment fait-on quand on a un enfant
comme celui-là rester avec une question
est sans doute pas la meilleure manière
d'avancer et puis les années passent
alors j'ai appris qu'il existe des
techniques qui permettent de décomposer
finement d apprentissage et de faire en
sorte que pour gravir les marches de la
connaissance on puisse peut-être
procéder à un découpage très très faim
des contenus et puis ajustés
l'évaluation et mesures et non pas les
grandes étapes qui sont franchies mais
aussi les petites étapes et c'était
important
d'autant qu'en france l'autisme concerne
son 1000 enfants 80% de ces enfants
n'ont pas de livret scolaire
tout simplement parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'école ils n'y vont pas et pour les 20%
d'entre eux qui ont accès
c'est compliqué puisque leur temps de
scolarisation ne permet peut-être pas
toujours de bien constater les progrès
et puis on nous dit souvent comment
voulez vous l'évaluez il n'a pas de
langage
comment lever ces barrières pour
comprendre où il en est je suis
longtemps resté avec cette question
longtemps en deux ans et puis mon métier
n'était pas l'éducation mais j'avais
appris en marketing en gestion de projet
qu'ont réussi à inventer des solutions
et qu'on peut inventer des solutions
quand elle n'existe pas que quand un
sujet est important il faut faire face
et il faut construire
c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai pensé qu'il serait important aussi
de rassembler des professionnels qui
maîtrisent ces techniques et qu'ensemble
on pourrait peut-être faire ce qui
n'existe pas le livret scolaire de ces
enfants extraordinaires les tablettes
tactiles constitue pour beaucoup
d'enfants ordinaire au moins ordinaire
un grand levier de motivation et c'est
pourquoi nous avons pensé que ce serait
un excellent moyen pour lever les
barrières permettre d'objectiver la
maîtrise d'une compétence faire en sorte
que l'enfant puisse toucher les réponses
plutôt que de les dire par exemple et
c'est comme ça que j'ai réuni des
orthophonistes des enseignants des
psychologues des ergots et bien d'autres
encore autour d'un projet learn and joy
qui a finalement consisté à mettre un
manuel très détaillés dans des tablettes
est allé diffusé par internet les
enfants avec autisme ont pu ainsi lever
un certain nombre de barrières
inhérentes à leur handicap et apprendre
ce qui nous a semblé intéressant c'était
de définir une temporalité identique à
l'évaluation et au temps de travail pour
enlever tous les biais les billets de
lieux de personnes puisque ces enfants
ont des difficultés à transposer ce
qu'ils savent d'un milieu à l'autre et
la temporalité
maintenant peut être la même quand un
enfant touché un écran en même temps
qu'il répond on peut stocker sa réponse
faire en sorte qu'elles soient
enregistrées et faire en sorte qu'elles
permettent de comprendre si une
compétence et maîtriser ou ne l'est pas
et surtout en même temps que l'enfant
travail s'amuse apprend nous avons eu la
possibilité de faire en sorte que le coc
éducateurs ajuste sa proposition
pédagogique s'il ne sait pas on lui
repose la question et on lui donne
l'occasion d'apprendre
il ne reste pas sur un échec
pour vous donner un exemple très concret
l'apprentissage des catégories par
exemple vous allez sur un enfant au
développement ordinaire directement allé
à la marche numéro 5
un enfant sait très bien qu'une banane
et une pomme sont associés ensemble pour
un enfant qui a des troubles du
développement ou des troubles du
comportement ou des troubles de
concentration
peut-être même aussi pour un enfant
allophones primo arrivants vous allez
avoir quelques étapes intermédiaires qui
pourront l'aider mettre la table sur la
table des appariements d'objets
identique
ensuite des appariements d'objets
identique avec un intrus comme l'étape 2
puis gardé un intrus et mettre plusieurs
exemplaires puis passer aux associations
les chaussettes avec les chaussures les
couteaux avec les fourchettes et enfin
passer aux catégories et aux fonctions
des objets pour accéder aux compétences
parfois il faut un peu de patience
parfois il faut juste se déguster au
rythme de l'élève mais c'est possible et
si on sait exactement où il en est la
pédagogie différenciée n'est plus un
principe un voeu pieux grâce au
numérique elle devient une vraie
possibilité
le numérique permet de faciliter
l'utilisation de nos manuels mais il
permet autres choses encore il permet de
partager les résultats et le livret
scolaire tel que nous l'avons conçu nous
avons voulu qu'il puisse être édité en
fin de trimestre bien sûr en valorisant
tous les items de connaissances de
compétences d'éléments de culture du
socle commun dont nous sommes évidemment
très proches mais nous avons aussi voulu
qu'ils puissent être édité à tout moment
car les enfants avec handicap sont
souvent scolarisés dans plusieurs
établissements dans une école mais aussi
annie et me un sessad un hôpital de jour
et notre société organise
pour eux malheureusement un parcours
complètement morcelé ou des spécialistes
interviendront ont toute bienveillance
avec une expertise mais très
ponctuellement et finalement la vision
globale de l'élève
personne ne l'aura avec cette
possibilité d'éditer en un seul clic
tout ce qui a été travaillé acquis ou
est en cours d'acquisition touléco
éducateurs peuvent constituer une
communauté cohérente autour de l'enfant
et se partage c'est quelque chose qui
s'appelle le cloud qui paraît très
mystérieux mais c'est ça qui le permet
quand il est bien utilisé
je crois que c'est essentiel pour
avancer il nous fallait aussi trouver
des partenaires et nous nous sommes
logiquement tournés vers le ministère
qui s'occupe le plus d'éducation qui est
le ministère de l'éducation nationale et
j'ai frappé à la porte du handicap du
numérique et nous avons été entendus
je crois que les révolutions les plus
importantes on peut lui faire avec les
partenaires en place je suis persuadé
que ce sujet rassemble localement il
peut diviser car c'est difficile
d'accueillir un enfant comme celui là
dans une classe mais la question de
l'évaluation qui est tellement
nécessaires à l'accueil des enfants
quand ils sont cent mille plusieurs
centaines de milliers est une vraie
question et je suis persuadé que les
pouvoirs publics comme les entrepreneurs
sociaux les enseignants les inspecteurs
des bénévoles
tout le monde peut se rassembler pour
construire les solutions qui n'existe
pas aujourd'hui je voudrais simplement
vous dire que rien ne me prédestinait à
travailler dans l'univers de l'éducation
mais que face à un problème il existe
toujours des opportunités de se
rassembler et pour qu'un enfant puisse
aller à l'école même quand il a un
handicap à plus de 80% comme celui là il
doit montrer qu'il est capable on doit
l'aider
montrer qu'il est capable et on doit
prendre le risque d'objectiver ce qu'il
ne sait pas mais aussi ce qu'il sait et
ça c'est vraiment vraiment important
alors peut-être la prochaine fois que
vous aurez entre vos mains un livret
scolaire et que ce livret scolaire
valorise de grandes marches qui ont été
franchies ou de toute petite marche
peut-être que vous pourrez vous demande
et non pas qui est cette enfant mais
bien où il en est de son parcours et
comment à partir de là l'accompagner
dans son chemin vers la connaissance
j'en passe